ねえ、ごみを出してもらえますかええと、聞いてい
ますかええ、何を言ったの
ですかドーゲンを聞いていますか
ごみを出してもらえないかと尋ね
ました
私たちは今あなたが真剣ではありません。先週同じ会話をしたことはありません。あなたが
今しているのと同じ
ように私が
あなたの電話で演奏する
こともできません。
アマゾンの箱からゴミがいっぱい入っていて、
残ったカレーが全部汚れているので、ゴミを出して
みませんか。カレーよりもゴミが多いです。 お皿とあなた
は私たちがこれに同意したゴミを取り出しますなぜ
私は皿を作ることができずあなた
はゴミを取り出します
イエス・キリストそれは先週あなたが言ったのと同じことです
ロメオは
採石場でデコレータウナモトドームをします タカラ
300またはアセティック時代私が
知っているコラソン
ジャナナンデフォラDdouZ dou Z avocados
no koto
Oh God Oh God can I Dawson akuto Oh Cotton or Cotton
a demo copy not
Capistrano Cara menon kota connie stay
mmm kota so should got fancy ええ、
コタに来て今夜の警官を拒否し
ますイマンイマン大丈夫ジェイソン私はあなたにすべての警官に気づきます